à propos des voyages annulés à cause de
la pandémie
une demande d'action collective a été
déposée contre le ficav le fonds
d'indemnisation des clients des agences
de voyages vous allez trouver les infos
là dessus sur notre site internet
l'action allègue que le ficav aurait dû
rembourser les voyages annulés depuis
longtemps l'office la protection du
consommateur qui gère le ficav conteste
la demande d'actions collectives qui est
au stade d'autorisation deux choses là
dessus d'abord il ya plus de 36000
demande donc les fonds sont insuffisants
et ça c'est déjà un problème
et n'oubliez pas qu'il est probable que
les compagnies aériennes vous rembourse
elle-même directement parce que le
gouvernement fédéral le promis
l'industrie aérienne aura droit à un
sauvetage financier mais à condition que
vous soyez remboursés par ailleurs un
couple de rimouski a choisi de
poursuivre directement air transat à la
cour des petites créances et vient
d'obtenir gain de cause
le juge a ordonné à transat de lui
rembourser en argent et non pas en
crédits voyage vous trouverez plus de
détails sur ce jugement sur notre site
internet
[Musique]